how much time did you have to prepare
for your character Casey on the horizon
2 months would you say yeah 2 months and
we and we talked every day I mean we
became very close at that time we talked
nearly every day wouldn't you say yeah
it's important you have to have like a
we've talked about we need you need to
have this kind of French because free me
if I feel that it's just purely work
don't talk to me but I'm gonna be there
just for a work and then I'm out I don't
want those people I need it's important
because for me does I like this guy I
want to work with him again if it was
just pure work I don't really care about
you just we have something just too
formal and professional dish I don't
want that I want this kind of freedom of
yeah we're friend if you need me call me
anytime you're ready call me at like
whatever 2:00 a.m. my times like I got
an amazing news I'm like a cool no
problem you need to at least kind of
come and just happen thank you yeah but
it's funny to have like this I did two
months of preparation that we went
through everything custom why's that
jacket and he showed me some jacket we
looked at so many jackets to arrive at
this jacket just we get jacket over and
it's from Montreal
it's from Montreal there's a thrift shop
and it's got but he took that time
that's the thing he I like him because
he we took the time to I had a vision
for the the boots the jeans the jacket
the hair that this car yeah that could
the car everything so we took the time
and he he was a soldier he went on
flying took pictures selfie I was like
yeah no I don't selfie I try not to but
yeah besides just the aesthetics I mean
I was doing I was note booking
we had precedent films that we that we
had decided or that he had handed down
to me and we had spoken on of films that
we had felt that either reflected the
tone of the film as a whole or the
character but yeah but doesn't think at
almost what every two days whatever he
it was important for me to go over to
script what what is your thought do you
have any questions is there lines that
doesn't make sense for you is there
thing you you would like to change for
me I'm always open to anything because I
don't want to be a dictator I wanna be
he's an artist I want him to bring his
artistry to my film
so anything I'm like super wide open and
everyone we're shooting at the hotel
room we came with his note that's seen I
don't know I think what about this this
this this and it was away it was way
better so it's important to be open to
have this kind of a collaboration
otherwise you're killing if in if you do
if you're just trying if you're trying
to be a dictator all the time no this is
my idea my writing might this might like
no I don't I don't care just use it
twist it make it better and even in the
big white desert scene you tweak
somewhere just to make him more natural
for him sometime the way I write it
there was some time the way I write it's
very franglish French Anglo so I needed
that some time a guy a pure English to
just make it more natural there's some
poutine grease on the script pages
sometimes there at what point did you
two meet in person after all these phone
calls and these skypes and the first
time a shooting really okay I was like
hey let's high let's shoot it was the
same thing for everyone I never did a
casting in person
it was always yes Skype Facebook
whatever and then it's like let's go we
meet that's we shoot right away because
you were in Montreal money-wise and but
I don't believe that you're gonna be
better if I'm in the room I really
believe that I think that Skype whatever
and I think you're gonna be better if
you're doing live with me than if you're
just trying to have a reader with your
paper is like oh and he was better when
we did it together because I can really
tell him what to you the direction to
take change do sort of try this think
about this about the character and it
was better so this is my method it
doesn't mean that it works for everyone
but for me it works anyway I've been
doing the same thing for 15 years and
it's been kind of working so far so and
into his credit Pascal's credit I mean
he was very open to the the
collaborative the collaborative element
of filmmaking and I think that's very
often lost in actors Minds where you're
aiming to please you're aiming to you're
really just aiming to get the approval
of whomever it is you are seeking
whatever be casting producers the
director when you're on set and you know
I think it
best and I think that it's it's the
nature of this business to be a
collaborative effort and and as such
he's bringing things to the table and
I'm bringing things to the table and I
feel like that's the responsibility the
actor that's what it's really what
you're getting hired for is bringing
those yeah that those sorts of choices
and those sorts of even contentions to
the table and in that way you you the
Hegelian dialectic you know yeah I
always believe that through me as a
director I want to be surprised I want
to be like an audience so I'm like I'm
giving you your circle of a direction
this is this is your bubble to play with
go have fun and then impress me and then
bring something that I didn't think
about and you did it a couple of things
that I was just like oh that's way
better than what I could have written or
something
well Pascale you've said that you put a
lot of yourself into every story yeah
so did you give Tyler a backstory about
Casey whoever you envisioned his wounds
war were that the audience doesn't
necessarily know but that might be the
reason for his rage in the film or
different dynamics did we do a lot of
Bexar I think them I think it was mostly
my back story that I told you about yeah
and then you left the and then he left
the specifics to me yeah really
which was cool because in that way if I
totally tried to absorb his story off of
this it would have been too impersonal
for me so it was more of drawing upon
okay what place in your life were you at
and and where is that reflected in the
script and then for me to sort of Ally
that up with my own experiences and then
bring those to the table because if I
just tried to live his story and yeah it
would have been having a french-canadian
there's anything wrong with that but I
saw the camera yeah but that thing is
super personal for me and that's why it
was for me important that I told him my
backstory of why Casey is like that
because of me and the same thing for
Alyssa and all those people so I gave
them to everyone a little backstory but
at the same time I'm I'm a big opener to
just go off and this is your character
as long as you fit my vision I'm fine
with it and if there's something wrong
I'm gonna
move you around refocus but it's
important for him he's the one living it
I'm the one behind a camera trying to do
something great but he's the one making
him alive and making choices so it's
important that he lives Casey and some
of the best moments really were when
when you know I would go to him I said
hey I'm gonna try something here and
he'd say you want to tell me what it is
I said no and they would just do it and
it was and then he celebrated it yeah
but he gave me the freedom and the space
to be able to try things and that and
that was what made working on this film
such a luxury really as an actor on the
last shoot were you sad to see Casey go
case Italian Casey JC no he's right here
no but was this was a side I was not
really sad it was more like a relief
that it's never gonna be away that's the
thing I'm still him he's still
Casey and he's gonna live on now for the
film and so it's gonna I'm sure hope and
there's gonna have X some people so no I
think he's just gonna grow and grow and
I think now in a society that Casey is
is everywhere is it hard it does it does
but I'm just wondering is it hard to let
a character go especially if it's close
to who your story might be or some
feelings you have inside a little bit
but then after that you go with the
editing and then use transform it again
and then is the release of the film and
all that so is there's always some new
ways of reliving it and I'm sure in my
next one there's some you know there's
gonna be a new Casey sure new character
that's gonna be another part of me so no
I think no I'm good with it
I'm not I'm gonna cry over it well for
me from a from a different side it is so
difficult to to leave the character
behind in a sense that
certain affectation certain certain
feelings that I had that I had built
that I built within myself I couldn't
shake him right off the bat I mean
there's a lot of things too and like
when you develop a relationship the way
that that we did on the on the film
between Casey and Alyssa you know a lot
there's a lot of there's a lot of
carryover on something like that and you
you really got to remember that it's a
it's a job and but yeah I mean you ask
just I mean you feel those feelings
later and and even though you can
remember creating them I mean it's it's
a very it's an interesting process I
mean it's a very intimate process doing
us doing a love story of the variety
that we did and and it was taxing on me
personally I could probably use some
therapy after but I think what is great
is that that's why I'm not sad to let it
go it's because I love this kind of
melancholy
feeling about that is now as a it's kind
of a souvenir it's just it's it's out
there and you just I know I love this
kind of a melancholy sadness oh I wish I
can go back but then that's the beauty
of it I don't want to go back now it's
done I didn't I did the best that we
could and now the next one is gonna have
a new souvenir new memories that is
gonna be different but I don't know I
love this melancholy there's a beauty in
the longing exactly
you